foreign
[Music]
crocodile watch now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
thank you
thanks
sir no payments on the house enjoy it
it's delicious delicious
[Music]
oh well
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
thanks
hello where's your number
no no no no no no Hector we told you
after last time no more that was just my
song and dance routine my new actor will
love your minds prepare yourself for the
dance the first ingredients yes
that's enough thank you
maybe maybe
go back to singing oh security
seriously dude
ditch the birds
you got to show them something they've
never seen before
because whatever that was ain't working
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi
I'm looking for something something
unusual
but cute really really cute also
affordable
like him I can fit under my hat
why I'm dancing
we got a special and bird eating spiders
okay let's try this again oh a
constrictor
vampire bat
might have a lemur in the back
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
baby I like it like that
lion lion
foreign
Ty start a stage and scream at your
service
[Music]
favorite video friend welcome home
badly now
okay let's go
[Music]
Allah
come on Lyle I know you don't talk but
you can't sing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
skipping down
hang up that hot when the show shuts
down but when the world says you ain't
quite world renowned don't count
yourself out yet
it's the only way left to go you're
meant to reinvent the show so ain't your
blood we met
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so take a look at us now
you already owe me for the last show yes
but this one's special then you pay me
up front in cash might be a problem but
I have something far more valuable
[Music]
well not perfect
[Music]
if you're out of sync if you can soon
[Music]
found out
take a look
at us now
[Music]
take a look
we had a chance
[Music]
thank you
30 seconds of curtain got a full house
up there a quick leg
[Music]
s